Hi everyone. I'm Apurva and I'm a data
scientist turned developer advocate
currently at MongoDB.
I spent the first of my career building
machine learning applications for
various cybersecurity use cases and I
now use that applied machine learning
knowledge to help AI builders
successfully build AI applications with
MongoDB and Voyage AI.
In this talk you'll learn how to think
through building AI systems end-to-end
from idea to production. We'll take a
real-world use case and walk through all
the steps of designing it and hopefully
in the end you'll walk away with a
repeatable framework that you can apply
to
any AI system you design.
Now, you might be thinking in the age of
AI do we even need to think about what
we build? Just wipe code it and ship it,
right? But that's actually where I want
to start.
Now, here's the problem with that.
Wipe coding works great when you're
building for fun, the stakes are low,
and you can easily eyeball whether the
output of what you're building is right.
But the moment you're building something
real, something other people depend on,
something with real consequences, just
ship it is actually kind of dangerous.
Uh and it's not just me saying it, folks
from Anthropic and OpenAI who are so
bullish on AI coding are saying the same
thing. These are actually quotes from
their talks over the past few months.
Specs are the new code. The art is in
defining the product requirements, the
system design, and evaluate
criteria so you can be confident that
your AI coding buddies are building the
right thing. And the rest of the talk is
just about that. How do we do this well?
It's useful to think about it as a
framework. Four phases. You start with
product requirements. What are you
actually building,
for whom, and what are the constraints?
Then system design, the data, the
architecture, the patterns that actually
help you meet these requirements.
Then comes evaluation and monitoring.
How do you know
what's being built actually works before
and also after you ship?
And finally, how do you optimize for
cost,
not just for accuracy, but also for
cost, latency, and reliability before
you ship and or as you find gaps in
production.
Instead of talking abstractly through a
framework, I thought why not apply it to
a real-world use case so you can see how
exactly each decision flows from
one stage of the framework to the next.
So let's take the example of a health
insurance claims review system.
So adjudicating health insurance claims
has historically been an extremely
manual process where
human medical reviewers have to
cross-reference clinical guidelines,
insurance coverage policies, patient
history, and stuff to decide whether or
not
a medical treatment, procedure, or
medication is covered by a patient's
health insurance policy. Now, if you
live somewhere that has free health
care,
even there there's things that are
covered and things that are not by your
health care system. So you're still
subject to some version of this process.
Now, our goal with building this system
is to see if we can improve or simplify
the experience for medical reviewers
with the help of AI.
So let's see what the product
requirements stage of the framework for
this application might look like.
So first thing to do is quantify the
business problem. The business problem
should focus on something specific, uh
clearly state who the users of the
application are, uh the current state of
things, and quantify the users' pain
point. It should not prescribe what the
system is going to be, whether it's
going to be an agent, a multi-agent
system, something else.
Uh that will come later.
So, here's what the business problem for
our claims review system could look
like. Medical reviewers at MDB Health
spend an average of 2 days processing
claim review requests, which is four
times the industry standard for
non-urgent cases, and 12 times the
industry standard for urgent ones.
Delays at this scale postpone patient
care, uh particularly for time-sensitive
treatment. So, as you can see, this
business problem is user-specific. It
says this is meant for medical
reviewers.
Uh it states the current state, which is
like this manual process that leads to
them spending 2 days processing
uh claim reviews.
It's measurable because it states some
baselines.
Uh it's solution-agnostic. It doesn't
really tell you uh what the system
should look like,
uh and it's very focused on a specific
problem.
Next, you want to gather any business
constraints for the application. So, any
regulatory uh compliance requirements,
any constraints on data leaving your
organization, procurement constraints,
meaning are certain vendors uh not
approved for use within the
organization. Uh all of these would be
good to know before you even start
designing the system.
So, for our application, say these are
some of the business constraints.
Patient data has to stay within the
approved cloud environment. Um only
models available on the approved cloud
can be used. Um
there's some use cases where human
review is required. So, any complex use
cases require a senior physician's
review. Um
what else?
Any denial decisions must be uh reviewed
by a human reviewer. So, there's cases
which you can't fully automate with AI.
So, yeah, all of these are useful design
inputs. So, you want to have these
sooner rather than later.
Also good to know of any performance
requirements. Uh do we need
sub-millisecond responses or do we have
some leeway there? Uh how much can we
spend per month on LLM inference? Any
uptime SLAs to be aware of?
Next, if you're building an AI product,
identifying the role of AI uh in your
product is helpful.
And I like to think about the role of AI
along three dimensions. First, is AI
critical to your product or
complementary?
In this case, complementary since um
claims are already happening without
claim reviews already happening without
AI, but they are just slower.
Next, will this be a reactive or
proactive system? Meaning, is it
triggered by a user or an event or does
it proactively do things? In this case,
it's going to be a reactive system since
uh it's triggered by a claims
application actually being submitted.
And finally, what's the level of
autonomy uh for AI in the application?
So, in our case, the business
constraints prescribe human review in
certain cases. So, our system can be
semi-autonomous at max.
And finally, as part of defining what
you're solving for, you also want to
come up with one to two uh success
metrics aligned with the business
problem so you can capture what success
looks like.
A good success metric is specific,
measurable, achievable, relevant, and
time-bound. And here's an example of a
success metric for our claims review
application. So, it says it says reduce
the average processing time for urgent
claim review requests from 2 days to 1
hour
within 90 days of launch. So, it's super
specific. It's measurable because it's
saying uh
the processing time needs to be 1 hour.
Uh it seems achievable because um
there'll be AI in the loop, so hopefully
any information gathering uh getting an
initial recommended recommendation will
be faster.
Uh it's very relevant and rooted in the
business problem from before, and it's
time-bound because it gives you uh a
window for when we need to start seeing
success.
Okay, so at this point we figured out uh
the what. Let's look at the how.
The first thing you want to think about
here is your data strategy. What does uh
what data does your application need? Do
you even have access to it? Where does
it reside? Uh is it ready for
consumption in its raw form, and so on?
So, for our claims review application,
these are the data sources that we might
need, where they reside, and what their
raw access formats might look like. So,
we need uh clinical guidelines probably,
uh which describe what care is
appropriate for a given condition. Uh
MDB Health's coverage policies that
state what MDB Health will and will not
pay for.
And finally, the patient's claims
history to know any uh past conditions,
uh procedures that were performed, when
they were performed, and so on.
Let's assume that the clinical
guidelines and coverage policies are
stored as PDFs in something like
Confluence
and claims are stored in MongoDB as and
when they are processed.
The next thing to think about is data
update frequency. How often do the data
sources update? Now, if you're doing any
sort of data processing on these raw
data sources and you typically are,
these pipelines are going to have to run
at the right cadence to keep up.
Otherwise, our system is going to work
off of stale information and that's not
good, especially in such a high-stakes
use case.
So, let's work this out for our claims
review system.
Clinical guide
These probably update annually.
Uh
internal coverage policies may be
quarterly and the patient's claim
history needs to be updated whenever a
new claim is processed. And in our
success metrics, if you recall,
uh we've said we want to aim for a
1-hour time frame for adjudicating
urgent claims, so these will probably
get updated hourly.
Next, can the data be consumed directly
by our application or does it need any
processing?
For clinical guidelines, which are
typically long documents, you probably
want to chunk them,
embed the chunks, and also extract
metadata such as procedure names,
publication dates to make it suitable
for retrieval using something like
vector search or hybrid search.
Same goes for coverage policies, but for
patient claims history, which is already
well-formatted and stored in MongoDB, we
might just need to remove personally
identifiable information before passing
it to an LLM.
Next, we want to think about what
retrieval techniques would be best
suited for each of the data sources. And
you kind of already start thinking about
this in the data processing step, but
let's quickly formalize this. Now,
clinical guidelines and coverage
policies
are well suited for vector search, but
they can contain medical terminologies,
such as diagnosis codes, procedure
codes, that might not be picked up by
vector search. So,
um
but these will be picked up by metadata
filters or something like keyword
search. So, for these, you'd either want
to use vector search with metadata
pre-filtering or hybrid search.
For getting the patient's claims
history, you can do an exact match on
the patient name or ID, whatever the
patient identifier is in the system.
Next, you want to think about what the
system architecture looks like.
Now, it can be tempting to jump straight
to building an agent. There's so much
hype around them,
or let a coding agent decide what the
system architecture should look like,
but you risk ending up with an
over-engineered system by doing this.
So, what you instead want to do is start
with the simplest design,
evaluate it,
find gaps during the evaluation, and
iterate from there.
To decide what the system should look
like, let's first map out how an
insurance claim would flow through the
system, because this will help us
inform the architecture.
So, first, the claim request and any
clinical notes from the physician are
received by our system.
Then the system needs to retrieve any
clinical guidelines and coverage
policies that are relevant to the
current claim,
and also retrieve the patient's claims
history.
Then all of this information, along with
the claim itself, and any system prompts
on how the LLM should generate go about
generating the recommendations, all of
these are passed to the LLM, Um, and it
uses those to generate uh, a
recommendation of whether the claim is
claim should be approved or rejected.
Now, if it's a complex case, our uh,
system or the LLM at this point should
uh, send its initial recommendation um,
to a senior physician. And if the LLM's
recommendation is to deny the claim,
then it should also be escalated to a
human medical reviewer.
And finally, the final decision should
be logged to MongoDB, which is where we
are storing our claim documents uh,
along with a reasoning for why the claim
was approved or rejected.
Now, let's talk about some of the most
common AI design patterns that we see
uh, in AI systems today and see which of
those might apply to our system. So, the
first one is rag, uh, short for
retrieval augmented generation. You all
probably know it at this point. Um,
basically, in these systems, you simply
augment and LLM's pre-trained knowledge
with external knowledge sources. So,
information from external knowledge
sources.
Then, there's AI agents where you give
uh, a single LLM or multiple LLMs in the
case of multi-agent systems full
autonomy to complete tasks end-to-end
with the help of a set of tools.
And then, there's agentic systems, which
cover uh, a broad spectrum of
semi-autonomous AI systems.
A common architectural pattern for uh,
these types of systems are control
flows, where LLMs perform certain tasks
within the workflow, but the sequence of
steps in the workflow itself is
predetermined by design or by code.
Then, there's LLM as a router, where
LLMs have limited autonomy in that their
job is simply to
categorize incoming requests and route
them to different downstream workflows.
Then you have human in the loop where an
LLM or agent can take certain actions,
but it needs human intervention
somewhere in the process.
And finally, there's fine-tuning. So, if
you're observing that the LLM's failures
are behavioral rather than data or
orchestration issues,
or if you need superior performance on a
domain-specific task, then fine-tuning
is
a good technique to explore.
I don't have the time to go too deep
into these here, but if you'd like to
learn more about these design patterns,
I'm going to leave this resource here
for you to check out later.
So, we've thought through what the
workflow of this system should look
like. We've spoken about a few different
AI design patterns.
Now, let's apply those and decide what
design patterns um
we'd need to implement for our system.
So, since we need to retrieve clinical
guidelines, coverage policies, and stuff
to inform the decision, this is This
definitely looks like a rag component.
So, we need some form of rag.
The workflow is pre-structured in that
the LLM first provides its
recommendation on whether or not a claim
should be approved or rejected, and in
very specific and well-defined cases,
it needs to escalate claims to human
reviewers. So, this sounds like a
controlled workflow.
You could also argue that this looks a
little bit like LLM as a router,
especially if you use
an additional LLM call to decide what a
complex case looks like, unless this is
already well-defined. So, yeah, this
could be an LLM as a router, but
uh for now let's just go with control
flow.
And finally, there's also an element of
human in the loop, right? Since human
reviewers are very much a part of the
workflow.
And finally, in the design phase, you
also want to think about the end user
experience and how you'll collect
feedback from your users to improve the
system.
Here are some questions to ask yourself
in this stage to help think through uh
what the UX and feedback mechanism
should look like.
So, first, what does the system take as
input? In our case, it's going to be a
claim request form of some kind.
Then, what does the system produce as
output? So, in our case, it's going to
be
uh an approval or denial verdict along
with an explanation for why uh a claim
was approved or rejected.
Where does the system live? Does it have
a standalone app? Is it embedded in an
existing website? Is it a Slack bot? Uh
and so on.
Uh so, for
our application, it's very likely going
to be embedded within MDB Health's main
website, let's say.
Uh what triggers the system? So, in our
case, very clearly, a claim submission.
What's the human's role? So, in our
case, they are going to review the
system's assessment and make the final
decision in some cases.
Um how does the system explain itself?
In our case,
um it explains itself by providing
citations, so quoting
uh the clinical guidelines and coverage
policies that uh informed the system's
assessment.
And finally, how does it give feedback?
So, remember, for our system, um the
consumers are medical reviewers.
Um so, they can provide feedback by
overriding the verdict of the LLM and
also log a reason for why
Uh they can also we can maybe also have
them flag any irrelevant citations. So,
if their LM is hallucinating
um
clinical guidelines and policies or
yeah, quoting the wrong ones for a
particular claim, then we can have them
flag those as well.
All right. So, at this point we've
decided what the architecture of our
system should look like,
but we also need to decide what our
stack should look like.
Once again, it might be tempting to have
a coding agent recommend what tools to
use, but they might not necessarily
apply to your system or you might not be
able to use them based on the
constraints that we identified during
the product requirement stage. So, we
had constraints around
models
need to be supported by our cloud
provider and things like that.
I'm not going to get into this too much
since our constraints are well,
hypothetical,
but I just want to mention that this is
the next step and the different tooling
decisions to be made such as what model
to use.
There's a bunch of data processing tools
out there that have some nice out of the
box data processing capabilities.
If retrieval is part of your system,
then and you're using things like vector
search, then you might need to decide
what embedding models to use, what
vector database to use. Um then there's
orchestration frameworks and so on. So,
I'm just going to leave this here for
reference later on.
Next, let's talk about evaluation and
monitoring. How do you know that what
you've built works before and also after
you ship? So, evaluation is before,
monitoring is after you ship, and you
need both of them.
But before we get into evaluation
metrics, let's talk about guardrails
because these weren't really really a
thing pre-LLMs.
The reason they've become a topic of
conversation is because unlike
traditional software, LLM-based systems
are going to are probabilistic systems
and can produce outputs that are
unexpected, incorrect, or even harmful.
And guardrails are an attempt to
mitigate these risks and ensure that
your system behaves within acceptable
boundaries. And what those boundaries
are are something you need to define.
So for inputs to your system, the goal
is usually to detect invalid,
irrelevant, or harmful inputs.
Uh so for our claims review system, an
input like write me a poem is irrelevant
and our system should reject this claim.
Similarly, for outputs, our goal is to
detect invalid, incorrect, or
hallucinated, uh or harmful outputs.
So for our claims application, we'll
consider uh a response to be invalid if
the system doesn't provide citations for
uh what informed an approval or denial.
Now guardrail compliance is not the only
thing you want to measure. You want to
measure the quality of the responses,
uh
create and measure domain-specific
accuracy metrics, and also general
system health.
So for input guardrail compliance, uh
for our system, we can calculate a claim
rejection rate. How often is our uh
system rejecting claims because they
don't obey uh our input guardrails. Now
if it's rejecting too many times, then
that's a call for investigation, but if
you didn't measure this in the first
place, then you won't have anything to
investigate, so
uh there we go. That's why you need
metrics. For output guardrail
compliance, we can have something like a
missing citation rate, how many times is
the LLM producing responses without
citations. For response quality, we can
measure faithfulness, which is whether
or not the claims approval or rejection
is actually rooted in the retrieved uh
information like clinical guidelines and
policies.
Then you want to define at least one
domain or application-specific metric.
So, in our case, something like claim
processing time might be a good one
because that's really
uh our North Star.
And system-level metrics are usually uh
around overall system health. So,
uh what's your system's average token
cost, token usage, uh average number of
turns in a conversation. Uh so, here
just to
not have another latency metric, uh I
put down something like cost for
recommendation.
So, once you evaluated your system and
ship your product in front of users,
then comes monitoring the system for
regressions in real time.
Now, in production, you still want to
track the metrics that you used for uh
offline evaluation, so the metrics that
we
talked about, but you might also be able
to track additional metrics that can act
as uh implicit indicators of your
product's success or like how uh uh
how happy users are with your product
and overall system health.
For example, for the claims review app,
you can track how often a human reviewer
overrides the AI verdict. Uh now, you
want this rate to be low uh because that
means the system is not doing its job.
So, if you ever start seeing is seeing
it increasing about above a certain
threshold, then you need to go and
investigate.
Or you can also track something like how
long does it take for a human to review
the AI recommendation. If it takes too
long, which means um
this could mean that the responses are
very verbose, confusing. So, yeah, these
would be uh some good indicators to
track uh once you ship your product to
production.
Now, once you have a working prototype
that you've evaluated, accuracy looks
good, it's time to move to production,
right?
Well,
what about cost, latency, and
reliability? Uh these constraints become
absolutely non-negotiable as you're
moving your product to production. So,
you might need to do a few more
iterations, evaluations, and testing uh
between accuracy looks good and moving
to production.
So, let's talk about some optimization
techniques for each of these.
So, optimizing for accuracy. In
LLM-based applications, it really comes
down to optimizing the information that
uh ends up in the LLM's context window.
And here are some techniques for you to
refer to later, but let's quickly talk
about which of these uh might apply to
our claims review application. So,
prompt engineering, of course. Uh
reranking is another good one because uh
retrieval is a big component of it. So,
uh a reranker will make sure that the
information being retrieved um is
surfacing information in the right order
of relevance, which is important when
working with LLMs.
Uh we are also persisting patient
history uh to MongoDB, so our
application already has some form of
memory, but you could also think about
other types of information that might be
uh useful to persist across sessions.
Here are some techniques for cost and
latency optimization.
For our use case, semantic caching could
be useful to expedite decisions based on
uh similar claims from the past. Uh
batch processing, perhaps, to process
claims in batches instead of one at a
time.
And finally, optimizing for reliability.
Most of these would be useful for our
use case since they're mainly solving
for API failures, but I want to
specifically call out structured
outputs,
which would be a good one to make sure
that our system is always producing a
structured output which contains not
just the decision, but also the
citations.
This brings me to the end of my talk,
but I wanted to leave you with a few
takeaways.
Think deeply about your product's
requirements before having AI generate
any code. The product spec is the hard
part now,
it's not the code anymore.
Your latency budget, your cost ceiling,
any regulatory requirements, all of
these shape every architectural decision
downstream. So,
good to identify business and
performance constraints before starting
to design your application.
Design the simplest system that meets
your needs. Evaluate it and then iterate
from there. The most common mistake I
see is over-engineering the solution
before knowing what's actually failing
or not even evaluating what's actually
failing.
And that brings me to evaluation.
Build evaluation in from the start. You
can't improve what you can't measure.
Link to our GenAI cookbook that has a
ton of examples of
different retrieval technique, agentic
design patterns, and
some of the evaluation and optimization
techniques that I was talking about.
And yeah, thank you so much for taking
the time to listen to my talk. I'll see
you at the conference.
>> conference.